m je vais vous demander de repasser
votre micro marinette pascal j'ai oublié
une toute petite chose tout à l'heure il
paraît qu'un jour il paraît qu'un jour
monsieur chirac jacques chirac le
président a accueilli qu'à voler des
fromages c'est exact
oui une voisine c'était donc le courage
de shame cortège de jacques chirac en
direct suivi par notre moto et viens
d'aller signer l avenue d'iéna qui
redescend sous les ovations de ses
partisans qui avaient commencé à
déserter la l'avenue d'iéna pour se
diriger progressivement je suppose vers
la place de la concorde
pour l'instant nous le suivons sans trop
savoir précisément si le nouveau
président de république à l'intention de
se rendre ou pas la fête qui se déroule
en ce moment place de la concorde
les bruits si contradictoires circulent
dont on dit qu'il pourrait s'y rendre on
dit aussi qu'il pourrait ne pas s'y
rendre
la meilleure des choses est donc de le
suivre mais cette fois ci au clairement
à ce qui s'est passé à l'aller bien il y
à des motards qui ouvre la route devant
la voiture du nouveau président mike b
vous partez vous partez dans quelle
direction la baignoire
pardon ou partez dans quelle direction
je suis navré je ne vous entends pas du
tout j'ai l'impression que vous
descendez vers le probalement place de
l'allemagne ça il nous place de
l'allemand avec jacques chirac qui est
ovationné beaucoup de gens klaxonnent en
voiture il salue les raisons qui soit à
la fois sur les trottoirs ou en toiture
et le rythme et je vous dis beaucoup
plus rapide qu'à gan aller
bien j'ai l'impression vous diriger tout
droit vers la place de la concorde à
benoît je ne sais pas si vous voyez
actuellement des images de la voiture de
jacques chirac mais lui-même demande
qu'on s'écarte un peu de sa voiture de
façon à pouvoir mieux négocier les
passages difficiles comme vous dites
dans les rallyes mieux négocier des
passages difficiles j'ai l'impression
que vous dirigez benoît directement vers
la place de la concorde avant que la
voiture de jacques chirac que prennent
la direction de la voie express à
eh bien non c'était une erreur elle n'a
pas pris la voie express elle continue
tout droit et accélère de nouveau
nous allons bientôt arriver au niveau de
la place des invalides
avec à nouveau toute une meute de
photographes de reporter de caméraman
qui suivent donc la voiture du président
de la république n'étant pas marché rive
gauche là benoît mas nous allons
maintenant
traverser la seine changer de rive
repasser et rive gauche ce n'est pas a
priori le chemin de la concorde qui est
assez étonnant à vis d'elle c'est le
manque de 2,2 finalement de sécurité
autour d'un homme qui est maintenant le
chef de l'état et apparemment il ya en
tout et pour tout deux malheureux motard
c'est assez étonnant et même parce que
ici les invalides sur notre endroit p la
voiture d'une action à continue elle va
bientôt arriver à la hauteur de
l'assemblée nationale on avait vu il
s'est attardé longuement dans son qg de
l'avenue d'iéna longuement ovationnée à
ses supporters il a acquis la saluée
abondamment et petit à petit à son qg de
campagne bien son parti les unes après
les autres et nous passions à la hauteur
de la concorde devant la population
les il emprunte le boulevard saint
germain sous chirac ne s'arrête pas il
continue il est en train de passer
devant le siège du rpr c'est la concorde
et semble se diriger à nouveau vers
l'hôtel de ville pendant longtemps le
boulevard saint germain
c'est une jolie qui attend jacques
chirac demain puisqu'il va participer
aux côtés de l'actuel chef de l'état
françois mitterrand aux cérémonies
commémorant le cinquantenaire de la
reddition des armées allemandes
bien benoît j'ai l'impression qu'on se
dirige tout droit vers l'hôtel de ville
là on va peut-être abandonné quelques
instants monsieur jacques chirac pour
retrouver philibert source sûre à l'itu
iard hormis les deux motards et la
voiture de jacques chirac est bien
huilée moto de presse qui suivent le
nouveau président ateliers qui auront
ainsi tout le boulevard saint germain
aucun autre signe officiel et les gens
lèvent les bras tandis sur les trottoirs
surpris son devoir passer ainsi le
nouveau chef de l'état
je vous rappelle que par rapport à cet
événement qui est toujours historique
dans l'histoire de notre république
les moyens techniques qui vous
permettent de suivre ces images et le
parcours intégrale du président de la
république qui vient d'être élu sont dus
à 300 techniciens et journalistes de
france 2 qui se relaient de moto en
voiture ses fautes ces images sont
retransmises de notre moto est montée
jusqu'à un avion qui nous les
répercutent ici et qui nous permet de
vous les diffuser vous suivez
actuellement à une personne en scooter
qui a enlevé son enfant pour le portugal
aurait pu dans la voiture de jacques
chirac a salué nous raffinons quelque
chose d'assez osé compte tenu de la
vitesse à laquelle on roule
voilà nous passons maintenant à la
hauteur de saint germain des prés
devant le café de flore où les gens
certaines personnes applaudissent mais
la plupart
regard simplement un peu médusé le
passage de ce cortège
voilà donc grâce aux moyens que la sfpi
amis être de notre disposition ce soir
vous pouvez suivre de seconde en seconde
sans l'avoir perdu qu'une seule seconde
tout au long de cette soirée le nouveau
président de la république élu ce soir
monsieur jacques chirac qui t'as l'air
semble team de rentrer à l'hôtel de
ville en compagnie de son épouse madame
bernadette chirac m chirac mais nous
somme a effectivement maintenant sur le
boulevard saint germain et il semble
bien que la décision était prise quoique
j'ai l'impression que la voiture de
jacques chirac s'apprête maintenant à
tourner
nous quittons le boulevard saint germain
pour remonter vers le sénat par la route
saine
alors là on est ils ont néanmoins eu ce
détour n'était pas prévu puisque les
motards ont demandé à la voiture
présidentielle ce qu'il devait faire où
ils devaient aller
voilà donc on a un petit problème de
transmission la scène premier que nous
ayons dans la soirée encore nous allons
voilà il est déjà réparé voyez monsieur
marchand sur le plateau nous parlent de
nos problèmes techniques nous n'en avons
eu aucun
ouais je sais tout premier jeu vous
disait daniel bilalian que le détour que
nous faisons actuellement par la rue de
seine en dessiner en direction du sénat
n'était pas prévu et le chef de l'état
vient de s'arrêter
où est on là benoît alors nous sommes
rue de seine le chef de l'état a fait
arrêter sa voiture ce n'était pas prévu
l'escort n'était pas au courant mais
chirac sort de 102 voitures
madame chirac vous êtes madame cher et
vous êtes en direct sur france 2 vous
êtes en direct sur france 2 que
pouvez-nous dire simplement un mot sur
votre sentiment ce soir on peut savoir
où vous allez madame chirac
et là les motos sont repartis à les
motos sont repartis ce sera un des
grands mystères de cette soirée on a
perdu madame la présidente
et monsieur chirac est reparti donc vers
une autre destination sans doute on sort
on nous trouve dans un tout petit enfant
et 106 rue de seine j'avoue que j'ignore
à quoi correspond cette adresse est elle
la voiture de monsieur chirac avec
chirac à l'intérieur bien sûr un
continuer sa hotte
alors nous aussi nous allons essayer
maintenant de la rattraper
sonia elle est partie à très vive allure
et derrière comme tout le cortège tous
les motards et c'est à cet état je dois
vous confesser que il est difficile de
rejoindre sa voiture et vous avez
certainement l'image puisque les caméras
n'est ce fait elles avaient continué à
la halle à joindre sont des images dont
que vous devez pouvoir continuer à voir
par le biais de l'art le relais de notre
notre avion émetteurs qui survole paris
en ce moment et qui vous permet de
suivre cette évolution de monsieur
chirac dans nom pareil voilà nous sommes
hors ue
il faudra tout de même compte résoudre
cette énigme avant la fin de la soirée
quand même hein parce que là il ya des
millions de français qui se demandent où
est bien descendu madame chirac ce soir
je pense que d'ici quelque temps
impossible résume son problème et voulu
déposer son épouse avant de retourner la
concorde ou bien faut-il simplement
retourner à retourner à l'hôtel de ville
pour une séance de travail
alors là il est carrément bloqué dans
les encombrements la maman se bloquer
effectivement dans un embouteillage nous
avait encore les images croix de là
d'autres motos mais ce fait qui suivent
la voiture du chef de l'état
précise n'est pas encore chaque fois
intronisé est nommé par le conseil
constitionnel ensuite qu'ils prêtent
serment qu'ils prêtent fait dans une
dizaine de jours à préfecture et vers
notre dame
la logique voudrait qu'on retourne vers
l'hôtel de ville mais ce que très bien
que nous croyons les clés pour tourner à
la concorde dans vous suit en vous
suivent noir vous inquiétez pas on vous
suit parfaitement vous suit parfaitement
voilà la voiture de
la voiture de jacques chirac se dirige
donc je suppose maintenant vers l'hôtel
de ville célébrant traverser l'île de la
cité
benoît est ce que je peux vous demander
de décider une nouvelle fois de vous
approcher de monsieur jacques chirac le
quai du marché neuf
est ce que je peux vous demander de vous
approcher le nouveau monsieur chirac est
en train de téléphoner on peut
s'approcher un petit peu de la voiture
benoît
là on est en train de traverser la seine
on a même traversé la saison doit être à
la hauteur du châtelet ou quelque chose
comme ça de l'ancien château et là on va
arriver à l'hôtel de ville
tu as fait le sentiment qu'on est le
long de l'hôtel de ville même la de loi
oui je vous entends très très mal nous
sommes au pied de au pied de notre dame
là et donc la voiture je vous dis
semble-t-il retourne vers l'hôtel de
ville enfin c'est là c'est la logique la
logique de paris qui voudraient ça
maintenant je voulais l'homme le
précédent détour pour déposer madame
madame chirac route ce n est visiblement
pas prévu puisqu'il a fallu à formuler
les motards de l'esport qui avait tu ne
savais pas et pense est allé directement
à l'hôtel de ville voilà on est au
colonel el youm l'instant
devant l'hôtel de ville et ses jets
d'eau
je crois qu'on va rentrer par la cour
intérieure là je crois effectivement que
la voiture du chef de l'état va rentrer
par la cour intérieure qui est censé
tout à l'heure lorsque nous l'avons
suivi nous l'avions suivi pour se rendre
à son qg de la ville vienna pour
rencontrer ses partisans et toutes les
personnes qui ont participé à sa
campagne électorale voilà où cela dit si
maintenant derrière l'hôtel de ville
effectivement ma mére la voiture de du
chef de l'état rentre par où elle était
sortie par cette porte arrière de
l'hôtel de ville
il semble bien que donc le chef de
l'état se destine maintenant à une
soirée de travail ici à l'hôtel de ville
et que donc ma foi les choses en restent
là mais en tout cas il n'est pas
question a priori d'aller à la concorde
benoît vous pouvez vous mettre en
plateau vous vois pas là parce que bon
on vous a bien suivi le président élu
est rentré on a juste perdu son épouse
entre temps mais ça ça va se régler
il faudrait que vous renseigner sur ce
point là benoît vous êtes là avec nous
oui je m'étais trompé caméra excusez moi
si je vous dis que nous sommes arrivés
ici
après cette course poursuite dans paris
devant l'hôtel de ville à derrière il y
a d'ailleurs des lumières visiblement
des caméras à l'intérieur peut-être la
fin je le suppose et donc le détour par
la concorde n'a pas eu lieu et il est il
faut dire que monsieur chirac n'était
pas très très chaud selon son entourage
pour passer par cette fête de la
concorde même si bien sûr il est tout
coeur avec ses partisans et qu'il donc
visiblement à du travail ici à l'hôtel
de ville avant les la journée de demain
qui sache on se chargeait que les
cérémonies du 8-mai ya un benoît vous
restez là vous ne bougez pas il se joue
ce que jacques chirac pourrait ressortir
éventuellement aller faire un petit
coucou à ses supporteurs qui sont
réunies actuellement place de la
concorde où nous retrouvons tout de
suite philippe gassot